carabine skis bâtons tout y est ou
presque l'environnement n'est pas tout
blanc mais ce dimanche matin les
adhérents du club de biathlon de
montesquiou sont à l'entraînement j'aime
bien la glisse mais il va au ski de fond
on a des sensations aussi aux tirs je
trouve ça hyper émouvant quand on arrive
à tous bien réussir qu'en ski très bien
qu'on arrive à franchir toutes les
cibles la différence et le freinage en
ski de fond tu fait déraper et là c'est
difficile sinon on tombe et en ski à
roulettes c'est on ne peut plus vite se
faire mal en tombant sur le béton ça ça
rappe mais après les sensations c'est un
peu les mêmes pour stéphane c'est même
le jour de la découverte un challenge
annoncé par ses amis savoyards pareil
défi de bien regarder où l'on redresse
toi
le début un peu gros mais ça vient c'est
vite donc ça et plus en plus il fait
beau l'ambiance est sympa donc des
découvertes intéressantes et puis
motivant pour recommencer le club est
lancée en
1996 par ceux de tir et athlétique de
montesson et le ski club des yvelines
avec la crise de la covile 17 adhérents
sont toujours présents mais le club a
rassemblé jusqu'à une cinquantaine de
pratiquants la condition physique prime
donc le ski de fond mais également le
tir avec une adresse et puis un mental
vraiment exceptionnel c'est plutôt
loisirs plutôt loisirs avec découverte
initiation et puis bien entendu les plus
confirmés bien selon leurs demandes
auront la possibilité d'aller faire des
épreuves de longue distance ou du
championnat fédéraux certains des
adhérents se rendent régulièrement en
montagne pour évoluer sur la neige la
compétition n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
mais l'entraînement accompagne le
plaisir 122 clubs sont recensés par la
fédération française de ski dans tout
l'hexagone quatre sont présents en ile
de france et roi dans les yvelines